hey 42 here Eric finiman made a pact
with his parents if he was a millionaire
by the age of 18 then they wouldn't
force him to go to college at the age of
12 he bought bitcoins using a one
thousand dollar gift from his
grandmother by the time he reached 18
they were worth 1 million dollars sure
enough he didn't go to college we've all
heard the success stories of Bitcoin
early investors Bitcoin has reached
highs of over $7,000 for just one coin
Bitcoin or one of its competitors could
very possibly become the global currency
of the world in the future
bitcoin is certainly an interesting new
force in our world and whether it
becomes a new global currency or it
crashes into a digital abyss there is
something even more interesting than
Bitcoin that will unquestionably change
the world beyond recognition I am
talking about the very technology that
makes Bitcoin possible blockchain
blockchain is so much bigger than
Bitcoin bitcoin is simply the very first
adopter of a revolutionary new
technology that is going to change our
world in the same way as the wheel did
the printing press and dielectric
spaghetti Fork
the idea behind blockchain was first
described in 1991 by a group of
researchers but it wasn't until a
mysterious person or group of people
whom we still don't know the identity of
under the pseudonym of Satoshi Nakamoto
used this idea in 2008 to create Bitcoin
and blockchain finally became a reality
a blockchain is a ledger of financial
accounts but digitized and decentralized
and this decentralization is from where
its power and immense security is
derived each block contains data based
on whatever the blockchain is being used
for in the case of crypto currencies
like Bitcoin each block contains a list
of transactions that have occurred
including the person who sent the
Bitcoin the recipient and the amount a
single block is by no means secure
because
the data can be easily tampered with to
vastly simplify things a hacker could
simply change the amount of a
transaction to be more than it actually
was to fraudulently extract more funds
from the system but when you have more
than one block they are linked together
by a virtual chain the subsequently
linked block will always contain a
unique fingerprint of the previous block
this is known as a hash if a single byte
of data changes in the previous block so
does its unique fingerprint or hash and
so the subsequent linked block is no
longer valid also every single of a
block down the chain is now invalid -
this could be many thousands of blocks
and millions of transactions this
mechanism adds significant security to
the whole system and makes it almost
tamper proof but not quite because
modern computers can easily change every
single hash along the entire blockchain
within milliseconds so then the entire
chain would be fraudulent but it would
still show as valid so the Bitcoin
blockchain and all other modern block
chains have something called a
proof-of-work failsafe which means that
any adjustment to a single block must be
slowed down often taking 10 minutes or
more to accomplish increasing the
security because hackers really don't
like time throttling of any kind
but also every single data alteration
must be backed up with a proof of work
it's just like in school when you copied
all of your maths homework from the
internet then your teacher gave you a
verbal beating because you hadn't shown
your workings lastly what makes a
blockchain so immune to tampering fraud
and hacks is the fact that it is
completely decentralized no single
person organization or server controls
or dictates a blockchain network such as
Bitcoin blockchain is collectively
stored and replicated on mass on a
peer-to-peer network similar to
BitTorrent but unlike BitTorrent which
has a centralized tracker no one
centralized server or corporation tracks
and controls who has what data on the
blockchain instead everyone on the
network which could be thousands or even
millions of people has an exact replica
of the same data file or blockchain so
its integrity can be verified everyone
on the network has to have a record of
the entire blockchain all the way from
its inception meaning everyone on the
blockchain network such as Bitcoin has a
record of every single Bitcoin
transaction that has ever happened
that's an awful lot of data as of today
the Bitcoin blockchain is around 200
gigabytes in size the key to this
systems integrity is that every
participant on the blockchain network
has an equal vote no one person has more
of a say over which transactions are
valid and which aren't
so for a new transaction to be approved
or an alteration to be made to an
existing transaction over 50% of
participants on the network have to
agree to it so if you want to hack a
blockchain network you will need to
convince or forcibly take control of
over 50% of the entire network in the
case of Bitcoin it's estimated that
there are currently 10,000 members of
the network known as nodes so the larger
the network becomes the more distributed
the data and the more secure the
blockchain is you know what else is
secure and private online counseling
would better help that's right it's
sponsor time I don't think I'm alone
here when I say that I've had family
members who struggled with mental health
and I found that after they sought
professional help it really did changed
our life for the better the better help
is quite simply the best place where you
can get private counseling they even
have enough and from my experience I
found it super simple to use if you have
been struggling with stress depression
anxiety grief addiction eating disorders
or anything else that is causing you
concern then there really is no shame in
talking to someone
bounce it better help is the perfect
solution because it's private and
affordable you'll get access to licensed
trained and fully accredited counselors
and therapists there lgbtq+ friendly you
can choose your counselor based on their
religion or non religion and you can
switch your counselor at any time if you
don't quite vibe with them the biggest
reason people don't seek professional
help with their mental health is because
they're either too embarrassed or don't
want to waste time traveling to see a
counselor in person
we've better help you connect from the
comfort of your own home and if you are
embarrassed about being emotional or
crying in front of someone
we've better help you can just turn off
your video at any time and switch to
just a phone call so you can feel
comfortable better help is cheaper than
in-person counseling and if you can't
afford it you can even apply for
financial aid pricing is between thirty
five dollars and sixty five dollars per
week for unlimited counseling you can
schedule sessions via your phone or
computer and sessions can be over video
a phone call or via text all you need to
do is go to better help calm
forward-slash 42 fill out an easy
questionnaire and you'll be quickly
matched with a counselor who is perfect
for you and you can start getting the
help that you want today make sure you
go to better help calm for words last 42
the links in the description because it
helps out the channel thank you never
before in the history of networking and
the World Wide Web has there been such a
secure and impenetrable way to conduct
business and communicate online as
blockchain provides every year an
increasing number of large corporations
are hacked and customers data is exposed
online for the world to see from large
banks such as JP Morgan to more intimate
sites such as Ashley Madison if you
think that your data is safe online
today you are grossly mistaken however
if more companies that are responsible
for maintaining large amounts of data
were to properly adopt the blockchain
system to store their data in a global
distributed and
centralized network the chances of that
data ever being hacked would be near
impossible and just because your data
will be distributed in public for
everyone to see on the blockchain it
doesn't mean that the world can actually
view its contents and see all those
naughty pictures you uploaded for your
concubine in the Philippines data
contained within a blockchain network
can be and is often cryptographically
encrypted
thus the data can still be checked and
verified by the world without ever being
viewable except by its owner and those
who its owner selects to see the
potential uses for blockchain technology
are far and wide reaching and crypto
currencies are only the first step and
the very tip of the iceberg for what
blockchain can and will be used for in
the near future without being
overdramatic over the coming years
blockchain technology will change our
world more than any other intervention
since the Internet apart from AI of
course I must say that to avoid AI
getting very angry with me and seeking
revenge in about five years time just
imagine this scene you order a free
course meal in a restaurant the starter
comes you eat it
the waitress have you enjoyed it you say
yes and the price of that starter is
instantly deducted from your account
balance the same happened with your main
and the dessert once you're finished you
walk out of the door without handing
over any cash or even using a debit card
I'm talking about a new blockchain
technology and add-on if you like called
smart contracts smart contracts are
automated rules that can be embedded
into a blockchain network and they
simply perform an action when a set of
prerequisites are satisfied this
essentially means that you could pay for
a meal automatically after you order it
from the menu you could walk into a shop
pick up an item off the shelf and walk
straight out of the door meanwhile a
smart contract is automatically created
on the blockchain that deduct the cost
of that item from your digital currency
of choice
a few insurance companies are currently
developing smart contract technology so
that a claim can automatically be
started when your car detects that it's
been in an accident or say a natural
disaster hits your area your home
insurer create a smart contract that
would automatically create a claim and
even payout without you lifting a finger
employers can use smart contracts to
automatically pay employees without any
delay smart contracts can make property
sales effortless and completely
automated
there is no doubts that within ten years
time every business sector imaginable
will be using blockchain and smart
contracts in some manner social networks
are also destined to run on the
blockchain in the future imagine a
social network where a large shady
corporation with highly questionable
business practices not wanting to point
any fingers Zuckerberg doesn't own all
your data and can do whatever they like
with it a decentralized social network
that runs on blockchain will have no
walled garden full of your private data
only you can decide what people can and
cannot do with your posts images and
videos because all your data will be
encrypted and distributed evenly across
the globe using a blockchain a system
which is so many times more secure than
any proprietary system used by social
networks today the most exciting part of
all this is that the blockchain will
enable freedom of speech like never
before in human history every person in
every corner of the world so long as
they have a smartphone will be able to
communicate and share their opinion
freely with the rest of the world via
blockchain social media no single
government entity corporation or person
will be able to stop you from saying
whatever you like about anyone or
anything because no one person or entity
will have control over the network we
will all have equal control in a
democratic distributed system blockchain
will finally enable online voting for
elections which has been put off by
almost every world government because of
obvious security risks and fear of how
blockchain is finally a secure enough
technology to allow online voting to
happen in the very near future kodak
recently saw its stock price soar
upwards after it announced it is
developing a system powered by
blockchain that will track a
photographer's images around the
internet and can even automatically
charge people for using them on their
website or in print media blockchain can
and most likely will be used to track
the provenance of food items and raw
materials used in manufacturing every
piece of wood brick and sand used in the
construction of a house will be able to
be tracked back to the exact location it
was sourced from and the company or the
peoples who harvested it in a rock-solid
verifiable way that is no longer
susceptible to outright lies and
fiddling of paperwork imagine picking up
a ready meal in the supermarket and then
scanning the barcode with your
smartphone your phone instantly informs
you of which farm the beef came from and
exactly whether potatoes and the veg
that's are contained within your meal
and because of the integrity of
blockchain you know you can trust the
information world governments are even
getting on board Dubai has pledged to
become the world's first blockchain
enabled city in 2016 30 governments
departments based in Dubai formed a new
blockchain committee purely to
investigate the possibilities to change
every government sector in the UAE to
use blockchain to make life easier more
efficient and cheaper for the citizens
of Dubai they are looking to enable
every sector to utilize blockchain
including healthcare records business
registrations shipping bill payments and
visa applications
considering that Dubai processes over a
hundred million of such documents every
year digitizing all these in a
blockchain could make a huge difference
some forward-thinking engineers are even
working on one of the most revolutionary
ideas of all decentralizing the internet
we all use the Internet
every day and it's easy to think of it
as a mysterious cloud that exists
everywhere and all around us like a
benevolent God providing endless cat
videos but it's not a cloud at all and
there's no mystery or magic to it the
Internet is just a collection of
physical servers millions of them in
thousands of data centers around the
globe the problem of this is that all
these servers and the data held upon
them is owned or leased by large
corporations I'm not trying to insinuate
that large corporations are inherently
bad not at all
but imagine taking all those servers and
evenly distributing them across the
world so now instead of a website such
as YouTube being located in just one or
a few locations it is located in
millions of locations across the world
no one person or entity has control over
the website it is now a group
collaborative effort that is edited and
run democratically by the very people
who use it and enjoy it every day you if
the Internet is decentralized it would
also make it infinitely more reliable
and anyone in any corner of the world
would be able to access it without any
censorship or huge government firewalls
true net neutrality would finally exist
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video then please consider joining the
private 42 community here on youtube by
hitting the join button below to get
early access to all my videos and
occasional short vlogs exclusively for
the members also do make sure you check
out better help by using the link in a
description it could be a life-changing
decision and there really is no better
platform or way to get professional and
personal counseling